tu es pour payer permettre une meilleure
intégration de l'islam en france
c'est en ces termes que le débat est
posé le figaro veille consacré trois
pages demain que vous aurez j'espère
l'envi de lire depuis plusieurs jours le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner reçoit les représentants des
cultes sur le sujet est donc ce jeudi ce
sera au tour des
musulmans du cfcm alors on peut voir
comment le ministre de l'intérieur
justifie cette réforme lui dit comme on
le voit s'afficher à l'écran ça fait 113
ans qu'on a pas que la loi existe on ya
peu touché donc il est temps de la
réforme et sa collègue ministre des
territoires jacqueline gourault dit elle
que c'est un sujet à manier avec la plus
extrême prudence sont les gouttes
c'est un sujet extrêmement délicat et
qu'il faut manier avec beaucoup de
prudence monsieur castaner a dit cette
phrase ça n'est pas tabou moi je dis pas
qu'il ne faut pas le faire je dis
simplement que c'est dans notre pays
quelque chose de très sensible et de
très fragile
alexis ces sept là une réforme
nécessaire ou c'est ouvrir la boîte de
pandore du bourreau 17 fois mieux on se
porte
parce que d'abord on sait pas quel est
son objectif est ce que l'objectif c'est
de contrôler l'islam
d'abord c'est pas l'objectif affiché
tous ceux qui ont essayé ont échoué
parce que sarkozy le premier et dieu
sait qu'ils cèdent et du mal et qu'il
décide de nommer un issam à sa botte ça
ne marche pas parce que c'est une
religion où il n'ya pas de clergé donc
pas de représentant et donc on met en
scène les uns y en a d'autres qui se
lèvent pas derrière que c'est
extrêmement compliqué qu'on a une règle
du jeu aujourd'hui qui la loi de 1905
que comme le disent
qu'est-ce-qui désaxé castaner elle
existe depuis sa touche et en plus c'est
facile on y touche
on ya tous et je crois que si la
transparence financière la loi la loi le
permet aujourd'hui on peut très bien
faire il ya du trac fin on peut très
bien savoir
on sait par exemple que la russie a
donné de l'argent là il ya d'autres
moyens de contrôler les financements la
formation des imams
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'une
formation alors on en fait c'est le
concordat mais lorsqu'il faut le dire
mais on veut pas le dire
la seul endroit on peut former des imams
c'est aujourd'hui à strasbourg il ya une
formation où on enseigne à peu près
n'importe quoi des gens qui n'ont aucun
d'ailleurs n'être imams parce que aucun
gars qui veut être imam ne va là bas
donc tout ça n'a pas de sens parce qu'il
faut laisser si les fidèles musulmans
veulent financer des lieux de culte ils
peuvent les financer il ya par ailleurs
des tas de facilité de d'établissements
culturels qui permettent de les financer
et puis après pour surveiller les
prêches il faut faire ce que je fais
aujourd'hui la lah des séries c'est en
formant les imams con qu'on arrive à il
faut juste envoyé de la police quand il
a regardé ce qu'ils disent points
fausse bonne idée eric naulleau déjà
c'est pas le drian que s'expriment sur
les questions intérieures madame goro
sur la loi 1905 c'est ça devient un peu
cacophonique la nôtre notre gouvernement
est moi je trouve démuni ce sujet en ce
moment assez sérieux et aux licences
ministre modem pour qu'elles s'y
consacrent hamas aux politiques
d'inspiration démocrates-chrétiens et
pour lesquels le point de vue de
l'église catholique compte et l'église
est très réticente à ce qu'on modifie
quoi que ce soit les protestants aussi
ellis est une femme politique on peut
pas à la fois dire si jupiter il laisse
personne dépassée les personnes qui
restent
du sujet ce n'est pas leur coeur du
sujet alors êtes vous retirer votre
marque il a proposé le conseiller
moi ce que d'après ce qu'on sait
évidemment que ces malades manier avec
précaution surtout que ses associés à la
question de l'islam donc ça fait quand
même beaucoup de choses et rodman
d'après ce qu'on en sait ça ne
concernerait que le régime des cultes -
il semble qu'il ya un besoin de
clarification avec l'islam ça ne paraît
pas aberrant de vouloir un peu plus de
tarification un peu plus de contrôles
mais en effet là je suis d'accord avec
vous alexis que c'est que le seul but
c'est de trouver une instance
représentative des musulmans de vent il
n'y a pas d'autres enjeux alors soit ça
fait partie des enjeux de cette de cette
réforme soit ça ne fait pas partie si ça
n'en fait pas partie en effet c'est
beaucoup de bruit pour rien il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut régler
mais si ça permet de régler ce problème
je pense que c'est essentiel on a besoin
d'un apaisement des relations entre
l'islam et la république doit lors
l'apaisement il passe par quoi on perd
la raison la fosse d'aborder ce débat
regardez là vous voyez ça toucher à la
loi de 1905 reviendrait à adouber alary
frères musulmans mais c'est aberrant de
dire des choses comme ça le camp
totalement aberrant d'abord la loi de
1905 faire lors des débats ce qu'on doit
toucher ou pas touchés
on n'y a touché mais je ne sais pas
combien de fois mais je ne sais pas de
la joie et de tout parfois sans le
mettre dans la loi mais dans le mettons
ailleurs dans le code des collectivités
locales avec l'état mais pour des
ajustements accès wi mélamine à la
question n'est pas non plus la personne
de dire on va supprimer la séparation
entre l'église et l'état donc donc c'est
absurde de ça si c'était quelque chose
de l'objectif c'est exactement l'inversé
que parce que l'on constate une montée
considérable des forces animé par
l'étranger utilisant le biais d'internet
d'implantation idéologique deux frères
mais elle est propre on dit alex goude
il ya d'autres moyens
yalla yalla
alors après car si on est d'accord si on
est d'accord que ça c'est un sujet
important et qu'il faut faire quelque
chose contre cela
après ça devient débat technique est ce
que la bonne façon de faire celle ci ou
ça et comment s'est même pas encore ce
que propose au monde au grand show sur
un touché qui est absurde puisque le but
serait la verse pas un sujet à agiter
avant les européennes emmanuel rivière
sensible européenne ou peu européenne
c'est même le sujet le plus éruptif en
france aujourd'hui pour ceux qui
effectivement faut aborder les choses
autant que possible avec beaucoup de
prudence
beaucoup de précaution et en évitant les
éruptions calculatrice
après voilà quand on donne les enquêtes
c'est vrai qu'un problème pose la
question vous un baromètre fait pour la
fédération des peuples sur la société
inclusive on demande aux gens de décrire
la société française et de dire ce qu'il
souhaite
leur description la société française
c'est un tiers une société d'origine
chrétienne un tiers une société
multiconfessionnelle et un tiers une
société laïque
description le souhait société d'origine
chrétienne un tiers sociétés
multiconfessionnelles 12% société laïque
50% donc à une distance entre le constat
est le souhait est donc il ya un besoin
d'intervention publique sur le sujet ce
qui pose évidemment problème de
tranquillité lamic lightweight sur les
deux premiers et laïque
alors la question était très très
compliqué à construire on a d'autres
questions qui explique ce qu'on entend
par laïque et d'ailleurs par là on
entend sur le 1 et d'asie pacifique de
toutes les religions l'entente liberté
de culte et liberté de conscience et la
liberté de croire ou ne pas croire mais
derrière tout cela se cache une réalité
enfin se cache pas du tout d'améliorer
une réalité qui est une majorité de
français ont un problème avec une
religion l'islam qui par ailleurs est la
religion de référence d'un nombre
croissant de français donc il ya un
besoin d'intervention est toute la
question c'est de savoir s'il faut soit
touchée à la loi soit 2 d'expliquer
pourquoi cette loi
effectivement là qu'il faut puiser les
réponses parce que c'est celle qui fait
consensus celles qui font consensus dans
ce pays pour
répondre ou clarifier ce problème une
religion émergentes qui est plus ou
moins bien accepté mais assez mal
acceptée par un certain nombre de gens
juste un dernier point alexis met
vraiment un dernier mot et puis c'est le
mot de la fin parce qu'on est au bout de
l'émission veulent y ajouter quelque
chose pour modérer la tentative un tout
petit peu d'effarement seyssois est-ce
qu'il faut adapter les lois de la
république
hmmm ça à cette religion qui pose des
problèmes de perception et de pratiques
que vous avez dit soit ce qu'il faut
conformer fussent de force
l'islam aux lois de la république je
pense que la propre terme de
l'alternative
l'immense majorité des français n'en
veulent pas alternatif ces six là bien
sûr quand on dit qu'on va financer des
mosquées et et financer la formation des
imams c'est bien qu'on va adapter les
lois de la république à l'islam donc
c'est le premier temps invité et donc je
pense que l'immense majorité des
français n'en veulent pas et moi non
plus quant au deuxième terme de
l'alternative qui est ce qu'on va
conformer de force d'islam
au loin la république on pourrait
estimer en théorie que c'est souhaitable
mais qui font penser la violence qu'il a
fallu vis-à-vis vis-à-vis des juifs
l'histoire du grand sanhédrin c'est
d'une violence qu'on a absolument
inimaginable et qui aujourd'hui serait
absolument inacceptable et accepter ça
n'a pas loupé ça ne peut pas marcher
ça ne peut pas marcher donc demain les
français n'en veulent pas l'autre ne
marche l'autre ne marche pas donc moi je
pense qu'il faut rien faire ne pas
toucher à la loi c'est la vie deux des
trois quarts de nos internautes de jouer
75 % très exactement qui disent non il
faut pas y toucher anti mac cette loi
fonctionne plutôt bien il faut
simplement dire à certains musulmans
extrémistes ils doivent la respecter
citoyen en toucher à la loi de 1905 on
touche à la laïcité pour favoriser une
entre guillemets certaines religions
olivier duhamel voyez on en a parlé on
sait ne pas trop écharpe autour de cette
table poser comme question le mac on
refuse absolument de toucher à la loi
at-il raison ou tort
merci en tout cas beaucoup être les
quatre merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous demain pour un nouveau point
de vue
[Musique]